last week we talked to ronnie about the
severe heat wave going on in vegas
and ronnie's about to move there who
moves to vegas honestly
this summer in the summer do you know
what gets up to 120 degrees
in las vegas and ronnie has like
horrible skin for the sun
but here's the weird thing and this is
what i wanted to share with you
even ronnie hates the vegas heat really
the guys the guys found this great clip
from 2013 when ronnie and i were both in
vegas for america's got talent i had to
go out there
yeah and um and here's ronnie talking
about how horrible the heat was when we
got back
ronnie and i were in vegas together
ronnie got his he got all [ __ ] up in
vegas
what was wrong with you like you were
having my sinuses man listen to them
they almost exploded
you put your foot down like like by the
pool
and it it was like burnt burger like
like you couldn't put your foot down on
the pavement you couldn't have bare feet
you couldn't breathe and when we left it
was 111 degrees
crazy did he forget that yeah
somebody got a hold of him and put this
vegas in his head
do you listen to that tape ronnie oh
stop it
you hate it yeah i don't hate it okay
you said it was brutal uh that was a
one-time thing
i've been there a hundred times since
then and i've been fine
it's only gonna be 105 there today it's
already only wow
dude we were there it was it was 106 we
were going nuts
listen to this here's the weather
forecast well las vegas broke a new
record high with our temperatures
hitting 116 degrees
we are nowhere near out of the woods yet
when it comes to this excessive heat
with the
heat warning extended now through sunday
110 degrees though
by 2 o'clock and 1 13 at 4. that's the
forecast high today well we reached that
official high today of 113 degrees
and you know it's going to be a hot one
when we're kicking things off this
morning and it's 88 degrees
look at the time it's 6 32 and we're
already at 88 degrees this morning
coroner data shows heat related deaths
are on the rise those exposed to high
temperatures have higher rates of
chronic kidney disease and the heat can
affect the brain by slowing cognitive
function i don't know what you're doing
it's i've had heat exhaustion it is not
fun no i i pray to god you'll be all
right
yeah me too but you know what positive
we won't have to pay for a cremation for
ronnie the sun will do it for us
that's right right i'll sizzle up like
like a [ __ ]
uh piece like like a piece of paper with
a little mustache on it stephanie it's
gonna be 130 degrees today we can cook a
pizza around my ass